yes it's obvious how much work some
actors go through to maintain their
physiques for the sake of bringing their
characters to life but did you know that
this discipline is often a legally
binding stipulation written into their
contracts
probably the most well-known example of
a weight loss in an actor's contract
comes from Rebel Wilson who played the
iconic role of Fat Amy in Pitch Perfect
and its sequels in the film Wilson's
character calls herself fat Amy because
she wants to discourage other people
from doing it behind your back
and my real name is Fat Patricia
most of Amy's character Arc relates to
her weight and doesn't stray far from
the fat funny friend archetype an
overweight girl dangling from the
ceiling who hasn't had that dream in
February 2023 she opened up about her
contract on an episode of the podcast
called her daddy she told the host that
she waited until the Pitch Perfect
franchise was over to start her weight
loss Journey saying I couldn't lose a
massive amount of weight because it was
in the contracts for that movie you
can't lose more than 10 pounds or gain
more than 10 pounds you have to kind of
stay at the weight one of actress Renee
Zellweger's most iconic roles is Bridget
Jones in the film Trilogy Bridget
Jones's Diary Bridget Jones the Edge of
Reason and Bridget Jones's baby the
character of Bridget is constantly
lamenting over her weight the first
thing she writes in her journal in the
film is that her current weight is 136
pounds in that she wants to lose 20
pounds but the opposite was true for
Zellweger who had to gain 30 pounds and
stay at that weight for the duration of
the original film then regain and
maintain it for the sequels too after
all Bridget Jones wasn't meant to look
like a Sleek Hollywood actor but rather
a relatable woman whose insecurity about
her weight wouldn't cause the audience
to wonder if she has body dysmorphic
disorder hi
you like me just the way I am though the
Bridget Jones films won't win any awards
for spreading body positivity Zellweger
didn't complain about gaining weight
except on nights when she had no
appetite and couldn't bear to eat
another Snickers bar between the Bridget
Jones films Zellweger lost weight and
took on other roles however she was
contractually obligated to get back to
the Bridget Jones look by the time the
sequels rolled around
many people know Tom Holland from his
role is Spider-Man in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe some might also
recognize him from dramas like the
impossible or the devil all the time no
matter what you recognize Holland for
though you likely picture him as young
charming and cut one film where
Holland's physique was key to the story
is in the heart of the sea the film is a
historical drama that follows the wreck
of an American whaling ship in the 1820s
which happened to inspire a little book
called Moby Dick by Herman Melville
Holland plays Thomas Nickerson the
Ship's Cabin Boy and Lone Survivor
because the crew is struggling to
survive on very few rations the actors
in the film needed to look thinner than
usual Holland was no exception but he
told the independent that he wasn't
legally allowed to lose any weight he
didn't start out with because he was
under 18 during filming so he said I had
to gain as much weight as I could prior
to the weight loss and then lose it all
again towards the end of the film I did
lose a little more than I should have
but it's my art and I love it
some people know actor Tom Welling from
his role as Charlie Baker in the Cheaper
by the Dozen films While others may
remember him from the 10 season
superhero series Smallville which
follows a young Superman as he comes to
terms with his extraterrestrial Origins
and astonishing Powers I took a shortcut
through what a black hole Welling
plagued Clark Kent and his superhero
Alter Ego from 2001 to 2011. everyone
knows Superman as a chiseled guy in a
skin tight suit so it makes sense that
there would be a weight clause in
welling's contract throughout the 10
season run Welling had to maintain his
superhero physique without gaining any
weight on top of that he wasn't allowed
to play basketball his favorite sport
because producers didn't want him
getting injured impressively Welling was
able to keep his weight consistent for
10 full years while shooting the series
that's no small feat especially because
the show began filming when he was 23
and didn't finish until he was 33.
another franchise that requires weight
Clauses is Marvel which gives MCU actors
little leeway when it comes to changing
their appearance granted we don't have
any Marvel contracts available to review
but intense diet and exercise routines
are famously a big part of MCU actors as
Lifestyles so obviously learning the
martial arts is a big part of my
training but the other part of being a
Marvel Superhero is well looking like a
superhero characters like Captain
America or Thor are known for their
superhero bodies and are likely highly
discouraged from altering their looks in
any way before or during filming Marvel
actors are a great example of working
extremely hard to stay in shape over a
long period of time for example to keep
his body in a condition worthy of Steve
Rogers Chris Evans participated in
hand-to-hand combat swimming explosive
strength sprinting and mirror muscle
exercises if you watch the group films
the first Avengers movie came out in
2012 and the last film in the infinity
Saga premiered in 2019 some of the casts
were required to maintain the same
weight and physique for seven years
which is a major accomplishment
Bollywood fans will surely recognize
goody maruti who's known for films like
Zen doji tombsay and diltera Diwana she
has also appeared in plenty of
television shows including the 1990s
series sari Mary Laurie early in her
career maruti was pushed into the fat
funny friend category maruti never
viewed herself as the heroine and
learned to laugh at herself when she was
in the public eye because she knew
people would chastise her for her weight
contractually marooni wasn't allowed to
lose weight while she was working it was
particularly important when she was
shooting sorry Mary Lowry nonetheless
she lost 10 kilos or about 22 pounds the
executives were not pleased with the
weight loss and made her gain it back it
wasn't until after she stopped working
that she was finally able to lose weight
without violating a contract clause
the psychological Thriller Black Swan
follows a ballerina named Nina played by
Natalie Portman who dedicates her life
to dancing her company decides to do
Swan Lake and Nina gets the lead however
her competition is a new ballerina named
Lily played by Mila Kunis Lily is the
yin to Nina's Yang while Nina perfectly
dances the white swan Lily's Black Swan
is much more raw and seductive their
rivalry becomes a sort of Frenemy
scenario and psychological chaos and
zoos both Portman and Kunis put
themselves through the ringer for Black
Swan they had to train hard to dance the
roles and become wildly flexible but one
of the hardest aspects of preparing for
the film came from losing weight to
authentically portray a ballerina Kunis
shed 20 pounds getting down to her
all-time low of 95 pounds while Portman
shed the same amount she said she
thought she was going to die because of
the intense toll the weight loss in
training took on her body on camera The
Experience definitely paid off as Black
Swan is arguably one of director Darren
aronofsky's best films both Portman and
Kunis delivered critically acclaimed
performances and Portman took home the
2011 Best Actress Oscar but the
real-life toll on the actress's bodies
may have been too intense for any human
to safely and healthily endure I will
never dance again I promise you I will
never put on that point shoe ever again
another actor known for a weight is
Chrissy Metz who played Kate in the hit
television drama This Is Us Kate is a
complex character she teaches adopts
children goes through in vitro
fertilization and is involved in several
serious relationships however one of the
most discussed aspects of Kate's
character is a relationship with her
body Kate struggles with her weight
throughout the sixth season series and
even meets her serious boyfriend and
eventual husband Toby in a support group
for eating disorders part of Kate and
Toby's journey in the show comes from
their efforts to lose weight the other
night I stuffed my face full of powdered
donuts and then I cried myself to sleep
Kate struggles to take better care of
herself herself and her body so the
show's creators thought it best to
include a weight clause and mets's
contract in the agreement Metz was not
only barred from gaining weight but
actually ordered to lose weight along
with her character so that the
trajectories of her fictional Persona
and real-life appearance would coincide
you have to wonder like okay are people
trying to help me do they really want to
help me or do they want to benefit from
the situation
maybe it's wolf Mets claimed she was
happy with the contract though and even
called it a win-win however she did make
it clear that whether or not she lost
weight or remained the same she would be
doing so for her health and not to
satisfy a societal idea of what people
are supposed to weigh
who could forget the actors in their
iconic red bathing suit slow motion
running across the beach these scenes
are half of what made the Baywatch
television series so memorable the other
half were the actors like David
Hasselhoff Pamela Anderson and Moore who
inhabited the characters for years the
cast of this beachy soap opera which ran
from 1989 to 2001 worked out to maintain
their bathing suit bodies from season to
season in fact many of the actors were
afraid of being fired because of the
weight chains claws that barred them
from Gaining or losing more than five
pounds the cast discussed the Clause
with E news confirming that five pounds
was the most real weight could fluctuate
before it became a problem actresses
Tracy Bingham who played Jordan Tate
from 1996 to 1998 and Nicole Eggert who
played summer Quinn from 1992 to 1994
explained that if the actors did
anything drastic to their appearance
most importantly to their way they would
be in trouble with the executives of the
show of course because each episode's
plot pretty much revolves around what
the actors look like it makes sense that
there were weight Clauses in their
contract frankly it's surprising there
was even room for a five pound
fluctuation given that the show
premiered in their aerobics crazed 80s